good morning Hank it's Tuesday sorry for
the pause in our silly title thing but
I'm just immensely sad today
honestly I worry am i talking about the
protests in the u.s. might sound like
and could be just virtue signaling BS
it's so easy to make a statement and
much harder to do the long term
challenging complicated work that points
us toward a more just human story and
when I look at movements and
organizations fighting for that change
from black lives matter to we need
diverse books to partners and health
I see people who've changed the world by
responding to crisis but also through
sustained work that often received very
little public attention that said I
think it's important to acknowledge that
the root cause of the crisis in the
United States today is the ongoing
violence and discrimination black
Americans experience and have been
experiencing for over 400 years we see
this continuing racism in every facet of
American life from our education system
where schools with mostly black students
receive far less funding than schools
with mostly white students to our health
care system where black mothers are far
more likely to die in childbirth than
white mothers regardless of economic or
educational background I'm sure there
are people watching this who feel like
racism is over or like it's a minor
problem or whatever but I would submit
that might be because the political
social and historical context that white
people bring to understanding racism is
often hugely inadequate this is partly
because of the way we're educated it's
partly because we benefit from these in
justices and so may not see them for
what they are and it's partly because of
our information feeds not just on social
media and the like but also the people
we talk to every day the way you
understand the world is shaped by the
voices you listen to but it's also
shaped by the voices you don't listen to
to sigh just one example among millions
of what I mean many white Americans have
never heard of the red summer of 1919
when state sanctioned violence against
black people and responses to it
occurred alongside a global disease
pandemic I know I didn't know much about
the red summer until recently and so
honestly I don't feel like my voice is
the voice we most need to be hearing
from right now instead with input from
friends and colleagues I've made a
playlist of videos focused on black
creators and the long history of
african-american experience in the hopes
of amplifying those voices and those
stories the playlist includes videos
about the red summer but it ranges from
poetry to vlogs I really hope you'll
watch it with me and consider
subscribing to these creators also below
you'll find some reading and non YouTube
video that has been helpful to me
including a beautiful and wrenching
essay by Clint Smith as we've talked
about before I believe that how we
orient our attention is in the end how
we orient our lives and so I need to do
a better job of listening to the voices
of black Americans and to marginalize
people everywhere because I really
believe that when we listen with
openness and empathy we are moved toward
generosity toward advocacy and toward
justice Hank I'll see you on Friday